it's not I'm called a [ __ ] of a versus
no very pleased that the village of the
college are actually working together
because when I was there in the fifties
I didn't when I worked there for little
legend it's nice to think that they're
moving forward I think it's been
proposed would you be happy to second of
instead caps bonds counts the bonds you
have to second it instead Thank You
countess the fielding well I was going I
was going to second it if he didn't
because you've also got the real tennis
court just the other side of the road so
that has a lot of sports facility there
and okay it's been proposed and seconded
we have to get a vote all those in favor
thank you that case the committee
resolves to grant application reference
17 slashes 0 2 0 2 3 / ful excuse me on
to item 6 this is on page 49 of your
agendas tonight okay this is application
reference 18 / 0 0 2 5 2 / o UT and this
is land and buildings at the ryokan
occur Salem Road pros Boston and is for
the outline planning application for the
construction of up to 4 dwelling houses
and demolition or existing commercial
buildings presenting officers to
Atlantic stood over to you Thank You
chairman good evening this is an
application for an outline application
for the construction of up to 420 houses
with all matters reserved including the
demolition of two existing commercial
buildings that are currently on site
this is a resubmission of a previous
refusal of permission of reference 16
oblique oh three eight two two four
oblique
oh you T this was an old lion
application previously for up to 420
houses with all matters reserves this
application was refused on the 25th of
January 2017 this is our own
appropriation proposed vacuole access
and
accessed through Bradshaw closest which
I'll come on to shortly there were three
principal reasons for refusal namely
insufficient information submitted to
demonstrate that Vecchio access was safe
there was also a crossing of a public
right-of-way which was deemed to be
dangerous and also the means of access
taken through Bradshaw close was also
deemed to be a detrimental impact on the
neighbor community of the residents if I
turn now to the slides for this
application you can see that the
application site lights the western part
of the village of prized Marsden
identified by the black dots on this
slide the site is located to the rear of
japonica cottage access of self and Road
a small part of the planning application
site you can see here is within the
concert prize margin conservation area
namely here well it's a small overlap as
shown by this pink line here the
remainder of the site lies outside of
the conservation area but still had
joined the boundary nonetheless there
are several listed buildings near the
site most notably for grade ii listed
buildings fronting on Southland Road
numbers 2 and 3 south and Road Rose
Cottage
and also chestnut Bank which are
approximately 25 to 20 meters to the
south of the application boundary and
are shaded in red here on your screens
there is a public footpath that runs
along the access track to the western
edge of the site demonstrated here with
the green dotted line on yours on the
screens in addition to a separate public
footpath running on the eastern boundary
following further correspondence with
the county of rights-of-way officer and
there is a slight discrepancy on your
screen here whereby the dotted green
line should actually be running
alongside and slightly inside the red
application sites boundary as opposed to
going on the rear of the gardens here
bradshaw closed I've also included this
detail on your update sheets for
clarification and also that
correspondence is available on the
application file here we can see an
aerial view of the application site
outlined in red and in terms of voyage
being proposed here we have the existing
site plan this clearly shows the
footprint
the existing buildings and relationship
with the surrounding buildings and
properties we now have some photos of
this site its surroundings here we are
standing on the opposite side of South
and Road looking down the proposed
access road now standing on the corner
of this access road looking east towards
the village now standing again on the
access road but this time looking
westwards
up South and road including you can see
the Vic Euler access of Bradshaw close
here which neighbors the application
sites here we are stood on the site
looking at the larger of the existing
industrial buildings that proposed to be
demolished as part of this scheme in
addition to some surrounding scrub
vegetation this is the westernmost
element of the large Augustine building
with further closeup of surrounding
vegetation here we see the properties of
Bradshaw close in relation to their
application sites and the corner of the
large existing building as you can see
we're also here looking westwards at
number six to eight Bradshaw and some of
the trees that bound the site and what's
more in your Bradshaw close this time
including a bungalow here also number
before I believe here we are looking
westward towards the quarry more
property located on the Holloway this
photo is taken near the existing brick
outbuilding to illustrate the
southeastern part of the sites we can
also see the upper floor windows here of
the habitable veteran windows for the
whole Croft property and this photo is
stood next to the brick outbuilding
viewing the boundary gates the post and
rail fencing that separates japonica
cottage with the application site as a
means of a visual representation the
conservation area boundary essentially
runs along here the building line of the
property and also this hedge so all of
this area of hard standing you can see
in between here and the poster elephants
in addition to the park car it's the
small section of the application so that
is within the conservation area that
concludes my presentation chair just a
very quick
mean to update your refer you to your
update sheets there are three items that
I've included on there
the first of which is additional
comments have been submitted by the
applicants in relation to the impacts of
proposed development on the conservation
area the second update I've already
touched on but I'll a settlement mention
again obviously the small discrepancy on
the public rights-of-way boundary and
the third means to update is as of this
morning
there's been no additional comments have
been received for the press
advertisement that's currently out in
the Stratford Herald this era is posted
on the 16th of April with 21 day
conversations but deadline expires on
the 10th of May therefore chairman the
recommendation is the seasoning is to
grunt in principal subjects and no new
material planning considerations being
received by third parties prior to the
expiry of the press advisement on the
10th of May thank you okay our first
speaker is councillor sciocracy thank
you very much the presentation of Paul
Jones brings every mad our first speaker
counsel John Franklin from prize Marston
parish council please welcome thank you
coming tonight and welcome so you'll
have you have three minutes to speak if
you'd remain seated for any questions at
the end and I'll give you a warning at
the in the last 10 seconds if that's
okay over to you that if you'd like to
press the button in the middle of the
that's perfect thank you very much
over T monster I sent four photographs
which I hope to be able to show the
committee tonight to give an
illustration of what our concerns are
this wouldn't be my first was photograph
but that is from the drivers position as
you exit the site if you just move along
please
that's the car positioned to say that
you're approaching the village that's a
car coming through the village and the
next won't be a car going through this
you'll see how narrow the road is it's
approach that some speed as they exit
the village and the entry to the site is
not very far away from that that's one
of our principal concerns more important
concerned as one expresses by many of
the residents of Bradshaw closed that is
a very very dangerous area for
pedestrians we can't see any solution to
it so as a parish council we feel that
we can't support the application because
of this risk both vehicle and pedestrian
that's the point made on that the second
question I'd like to ask is that yeah
I'm sure you are all aware we are a
category 4 local service village and
under the course strategy those villages
were expected to take 400 houses give or
take and I know these are moveable
feasts so far to date those for village
are those 20 villages have had 391
planning applications approved buildings
commenced or committed which means that
we are literally 10 or 20 houses away as
a category for achieving or meeting the
targets and this is a plan that goes
forward another 15 years as a village we
don't need any more four-bedroom houses
the housing survey identified a need for
smaller accommodation now I know this is
an outline planning permission and if in
the unlikely event they come back with
two or three two-bedroom houses we'd be
delighted but as the village we don't
need and we don't want significant
numbers of more four or five bedroom
houses in there
thank you very much councillor any
questions yes counselor Perry thank help
sir Mills good evening that's the Parish
Council undertaken a housing needs
survey Housing Survey in November 2015
and that identified the need for five
new houses none of which were more than
three-bedroom we are in the process of
just to continue updating our videos
plan and the earlier indications from
that again supports those findings Thank
You councillor Mills thanks mr. chairman
miss Franklin good evening um you said
you'd be okay with it there were smaller
houses not four
five-bedroom but you still have the same
problem with access indeed we do yes
so I know if I miss the point were you
we were you saying you wouldn't object
if you had we have a concern however
many houses there can I have cause of
the vehicles and pedestrians okay no the
side of the house is it all well we
don't want the size a good beat it okay
I suppose it's principle of the
development yes counselor brain you'll
probably wear the high waves rates no
concerns at all about this application
and they said it's no more harmful than
the existing lawful industrial
commercial use so what's the difference
the difference is there has been any
commercial use in that property for
years and years and years and years that
were previously that was well known live
in the village 30 years and there's
never been a commercial view up and down
that track while the report tells us and
exist in lawful industrial and
commercial use well that might be the
case it just isn't in use any other
questions that case thank you very much
for your time thank you okay some
Williams our ward member for this case
welcome counsel ins sure just press that
again would you it's just gone off so
you have five minutes you know the
routine over to you thank you very much
you heard the parish council overview of
this application but it's the devil is
in the detail and I wanted to consider
some of the past facts there was a
previous application for this site some
eighteen months ago which was rejected
and that was a far more you could almost
say sensible approach to get into the
site but it was rejected by the highways
then lo and behold we have another
application coming now with a completely
alternative
we've never considered previously now
why not consider previously because they
realized it's a dangerous narrow access
point the developers have never talked
to the parish council either for the
previous application or for this there's
been no dialogue at all this is an
outlined planning permission application
this is very scant on details
interesting say they're not here tonight
either under why if you go to the report
on page 52
it starts from third-party responses in
effect that encapsulate why the village
do not think this application is the
right application for the site my
colleague cancer Franklin explained the
housing needs survey has demonstrated
there's a need for small houses
developers as we know like four and five
bedroom houses a recent approved in
price Boston is allowing for 4 or 5
bedroomed houses now if you consider
this applications for force for houses
in simple terms that could mean 16 car
movements a day probably more as they've
got four bedroom two houses down a
narrow road which leads onto a very the
road there's no details and the highways
have asked for further details in the
detailed planning application the
reserve matters there's things like x
and y disabilities having to come out to
join service and you see from the
photographs to the left as you come out
that site it's about 30 meters no in the
other minimum of 75 meters turning left
there is that clear visibility that way
there is the other way it does not so
first of all there's no pavement so how
these people going to get in this
much-vaunted community aspect or the
village have to walk along a very
dangerous road which has not the forward
visibility
I believe this application is probably
premature in detail it would need I
think further details to meet the
highways instructions and they give it
to us
it says here County average authority is
being consulted on the proposed axis it
says first access to the site in this
application has been revised from the
previous refusal for my permission
hasn't meaning right it's just having
changed it's not a revision it's not
manufacturing any alternatives to the
site and it's considered the first would
not result in any highway safety
concerns
well I'm sorry by walking people along a
highway where there's no pavement must
be some concerned otherwise you'd never
have any pavements anyway so that's a
main consideration I believe this has me
thought through I think the developer
hasn't been here it's a sight of land
that's been the same for many years they
deceased there now disposing of it and
that's really what this is is not a
planned development it's a disposable
piece of land Oh wash you to a punctum
house on it they're not thinking that
you should be thinking is this the right
way it might be the right approval but
it needs consideration and more detail
and I just think I can't accept this I
hope you won't either this present
condition
good evening Kelso do do he said that
there is no any provision for pavements
have there been any complaints from
people in brush your clothes because of
this because there's the same problem
yes
this will bite your clothes the
listening of disasters from being built
in the wrong materials to this location
in fact the preference was the people
from pressure clothes is a footpath
between Bachelor clothes and village
which is going out behind village that
sounds fine you have surely winter they
want awful home footpaths I think not
it's councillor fielding it refers to
Bradshaw the West the building it was
approved the small estate was approved
you know seven is that Bradshaw close
that was promote your pleasure to prove
me social housing under this was one
where local needs its only social houses
on Brett roads no private cell could I
ask would you mind just sort of
highlighting it yes thank you cancer I
brought bunch of houses closest here and
this is eight housing here as the
Watkins is crazy said I'm special
housing located here just to the west of
the application site can they have
access through a Bradshaw close to the
site to separate developments there was
no internet interconnection between the
two there either side of up of an access
road you can see we don't it's a
outlined plan operations not a detailed
plan information that's the difference
they've rather
skimped on giving us all the information
you need it's and outlined reserve
matters and come next okay
yes there was something very sorry thank
thank you chair
councilman's I'm just a little bit
perplexed because in the committee
report it's got you down as saying no
objection to this application I'm just a
little bit confused because you appear
to have come to the committee
well objecting thank you that
observation since I've made that comment
I've been made aware of many of the
material considerations that are
involved here I changed my mind as they
were over at title 2 when we speak here
at the time when I made the comment I
thought it would be more appropriate
development concept came here and
listened to things I read my own opinion
fair enough
any other questions okay in that case
counts all limbs thank you okay points
of clarification do we have any
councillor Crump
yeah general one in the update sheet the
expiry of the consultation period is the
10th of May there's any reason why the
consultation period ended before uber
after we're making the decision of
course answer thank you yes it was
brought to light quite late before the
previous committee where there was a
previously of recommendation for
approval that parts of the application
was in fact within the conservation area
where this wasn't previously raised at
validation stage and print and upon the
previous application so therefore
following statutory process and as the
council as it's a council we had to
publicize the application was partly in
the conservation area within the Herald
and to follow the G process therefore
the the application was posted in the
Stratford hair all of the earliest
opportunity after realizing that this
was partly in the conservation area and
the 21 day deadline as I say expires on
the 10th and the recommendation is to
grant subjects to no additional material
considerations coming in from the
advertisement in The Herald and as I
said I think as of lunchtime today there
have been no additional comments since
but that could potentially change up to
the 10th of May I mean I think it's
unlikely the 10 thing remember
anything of material consequence
bouncing it may sit what would be the
process should we remind grant and then
should some material and information
come to light what has been processed
there sure I'd like to live with your
discretion when you could bring it back
to committee or the better option would
be to for the planning officer to
discuss the matter with you
and then you decide whether you can
actually delegated or bring about to
committee okay everyone's happy with
that I mean I think it's very unlikely
okay any other poets clarification cap
I'm sorry can't understand why so just a
little bit more information so this is
it Thank You councillor Perry thank
council fielding Thank You chair and
council the brain can the Planning
Officers advise that if if we were
minded to grant this application whether
we could condition as the housing mix
under CS 19 which would have a greater
reflection to the parish councils
housing needs survey in terms that it
certainly would be providing at least
some two and three-bedroom properties
good thing
or nail thank you the the the challenge
with that chair is that there are four
different categories of housing this one
bedroom 2 bedroom 3 bedroom 4 and above
as the proposal is for 4 houses that
would be presumably one of each what our
normal practice is where there are fewer
than 10 houses on a development to
remain flexible on these things and not
to try to control it and in particular
with this site which is quite a small
site by the time you finish providing
access and parking and Gardens officers
are are reasonably sanguine that what
will come forward here are modest sized
dwellings she won't have four or five
bedroom dwellings on here so officer
suggestion it's not necessary and it
would be a challenging condition to
enforce but don't forget you still have
control of reserved matters sorry to go
on you still have control of reserved
matters do the size of the dwellings
reflect the character of the village
which looks like relatively small houses
in the vicinity that's what I suppose it
will come back again for reserved
matters cancer feeling from the looks of
things this is a brownfield site is that
correct that's correct yep
within the core strategy we've set at
the number of four bedrooms houses which
is sort of similar to the question
already asked how does this fit into
what the requirements of the core
strategy of percentage that we've got up
to within the district are we going over
the top on the amount of large houses in
the district they're not established in
the houses size yet are they well we can
answer that yeah council fielding cos we
don't know what size houses are proposed
all we know is the number of houses at
this point so it'll be so I think what I
can say very briefly chair is we're
broadly on
I'll get across the district well well
for houses Michael made material
difference yeah but they're all for
pigeon pose is it won't make a material
difference on 14850 right that's what is
clarification listen everyone's got any
other questions should we go to the
debate the brain matters combat they
will have detailed access details that
we will have to consider then so I'm
happy to go with the officers
recommendation planning permission to be
thank you Carrie
yes castle bonds you don't got every the
second main thing to address the
concerns originally from highways lawn
to themselves and I'm sure they're
getting sorties LARPing you might better
there's nothing you can do so I'm God
average the second the firm counselor
brain were you proposing that's thank
you okay
yes counselor Crump yes thank thanks mr.
chair I'm you know when sight again
yesterday on this look at the
application and my concern is I know we
go up by highways but my concern is is
the visibility and as that photograph
shows when I was pulling out of that
that track
I should like Beirut is opposed
everywhere it's not good on that corner
it really isn't and a a car came they
always look quickly and when you're
parked there you know when you're
stationary rather but sir it carry on
with it you know it's it's not a good
access I have to say I'm I'm not sure if
trees
be grubbed up so there's a better
visibly disability splays or not I don't
know but my concern is that and it is a
very narrow track whether I mean my
Lords are going to be a two way road or
one way because it at the moment it's
only big enough really for for one-way
traffic it's it's yes hey
again it's thinking about pavement on it
I I just I think the whole thing is not
good mr. mr. chairman
no I I don't like it thank you Thank You
councillor Crump
we've had quite a bit of information
from the highways we've also got the
opportunities to be said several times
already that we can go in the detail on
the reserve matters there's items in
here which says through submission the
robust ATC speed survey data it's that
it's been demonstrated this proposed
residential use of the site would be
replaced and exist all lawful commercial
use so I am very concerned that if we
did go against the the officer
recommendation on this one we would
potentially going to appeal one and
would begun against the Highways Agency
who are the experts okay we then almost
agree with them but again we've not got
too much strong evidence to go against
it
so I would be supporting application
thank you anybody else want to speak in
the debate
well okay I think I broad legs better
Hey yeah I support the proposal is so
proposed was that we grant all those in
favor please show against thank you
therefore the committee results to grant
application reference 18 / 0 0 2 5 2 / o
UT we go to item 7 which is on page 65
okay and so then this is application
reference 18 / 0 0 2 5 1 / ful and it's
the land adjacent to glebe on Main
Street along Compton and the description
is for them the change of use of land to
allow stationing of 5 glamping pods
presenting officer is Joseph Brook
Joseph of to you thank you Jeff the
applications to change the use of our
station of forums and pods adjacent
grief are blonde confident reference
1800 241 / full as indicated by the
black dot as indicated by black dot on
the screen is just outside long condom
the application sorry as indicated by
the screen in red line boundary is West
iran-contra by approximately 30
kilometers and it is located in open
countryside the site is accessed from
the 8,400 which is the main road
stretching through Java concen can be
seen here
Diana private access route which then
extends to the application side this is
an aerial photograph of the site the
site measures approximately north point
2 hectares increase in to null point
five if you carryin access and the Salah
is the eastern point of a large
agricultural field is presently grass
and lado
I which as a certified carve on site by
the carve on a motor home cook for five
pieces well that's almost assault visit
I did not see any caravans or associated
paraphernalia the application has
submitted the caravan certificate
license for five pieces for the rest of
the year however to north the site is a
large Dutch bar which is this Dutch barn
here and this is when it granted
planning permission in June 2017 for the
conversion of - holy cow holiday
cottages it's on my site visit this had
also not been implemented
as part of this application sorry is not
as part of this application as indicated
by the red line boundary both bowen and
the caravan sorry Arthur body resistant
tarmac which runs from the sites and
north for a distance of foxing 230
meters before and into before turn in
eastwards and 140 meters to the solid so
this is rate comes off not as running I
said 230 meters then it runs into the
field which is still got a tire mark
area of approximately 230 meters which
ends just a round of underbar and
there's the application site the sole is
wholly situated in the Cotswolds a OMB
this is the existing layout as seen the
caravan pitches this is obviously the
Dutch bond which is isn't part of this
application and this is where the 5k run
pitches are supposed to be decided they
have the lawful uses caravan pitches for
settle to part 5 Class A of the GDP oh
and with the car of unlicensed difficut
that is given the lawful use for a year
to use it the application if approved
will remove the caravans and as you will
see in my up they see and I'll explain
later a condition can be imposed that
the caravans will not be sorted within
the red line boundary and they will be
replaced as search for the glamping
bonds this is the pro site and as you
can see the dumping pots are proposing
the same sort of areas as the caravan
site additionally is you will note the
Grampian pots are also the same sort of
size and I mentioned I will show further
plans on this later on and yeah the
dumping approached Allah mentions each
time before are 6 meters by 30 meters
with an overall 18 square meters with an
overall footprint the heights of the
pods are said to be at two point seven
five meters externally
this is the photos of the site and this
is where the access comes in to the site
this is the Dutch bomb and has taken its
face in Northwoods outwards obviously on
the con side of the AO and B and you see
the tarmac area and I'll see the Dutch
banners not been implemented as
permission yet photo of the Dutch barn
just to show you what is assigned in the
area this is the actual application site
itself as you can see there is native on
there but it has been laid out on grass
for caravans to be sighted there and it
does have it under the law for use this
is another photograph showing northwards
I've taken this to Troy so the
outstanding views the AO and B and how
it doesn't sleep in parinama queues we
shall see look down onto the Afghan site
and also outwards onto the AO and be
found in the area this is safe and you
can just see food
margin few miles in the fields is long
contem village so there is some degree
of protection of the headlines but long
companies off see viewable through the
village and you can just make out a shot
of the Dutch bar now facing eastwards
into long Compton this is now North
West's of the application site once
again got panoramic views but as you can
tell and you will see in a minute there
is sloping topography to the to the west
of the site the north of site definitely
has the most panoramic views off the a
OMB and conversely this is north of site
a steep slope into ography heading
upwards and a small tree about on top
which to be fair when you got there when
you go out there is a significant you'll
a story about it's just shows from the
views and this is obviously sorry for
the site apologies this is a site for
the site and there's a tree about which
does protect the site and the panoramic
views the way that spot forward
obviously sloping downwards and it's
so itself does have a degree of
protection from the south of the soffit
and that is the end of my presentation
as you will see on the update see I have
included two more conditions if planning
is forthcoming one is not with standard
provisions of the Town & Country Act
social to pass five Class A this means
that no more caravans will be stationed
in the red line boundary also condition
two is to ensure the development as
detailed on the submitted plans of the
glamping pods will stay within the
specified host has six Mia's by three
meters and it's a two point seven five
meters and will not exceed and I
mentioned my officers recommendation is
for gravel thank you very much excellent
okay our first speaker then is counselor
bill cook the chairman of long copter
parish council welcome counselor cook so
you've been here before I think that you
have three minutes if you'd remain
seated for any questions at the end I'll
give you a warning at ten seconds my
three minutes go saying we're not it
wasn't thirty kilometers west of the
village to represent the objections of
long Compton and Barton parish councils
and the a OMB the history of this site
is of a succession of applications and
permitted developments beginning with an
ever used
agricultural bomb subsequently converted
into a little used office and then to
one and subsequently to two holiday
let's which don't seem to be used very
much permitted development for the
caravan stands which has hardly ever
been used I think the village has seen
something between six and twelve
caravans up there in 12 months has now
been exploited as the basis for the
installation of glamping pots this is
all we're told in the application part
of an expanding tourism center if the
applicant wants to build a tourism
Center in LA in only you should make a
formal application to do so not depend
on a series of incremental changes each
one of which builds on the previous one
it is time we believe to call a halt to
this now and to deliver on our
commitments to our neighborhood plan and
to the a OMB your planning officer
relies heavily indeed almost entirely on
the theoretical presence of caravans on
the site to set aside objections
regarding the acknowledged landscape
impact and the impact on our dark skies
policies it's unfortunate that having
the despite having been invited to do so
he chose not to consult with the parish
council before reaching these
conclusions had he done so he would have
been told that very few caravans have
ever been seen on the site and therefore
the incremental effect of permanent pods
would be really very significant this
alone could have been sufficient to
refuse this application and had the
planning office have been inclined to do
so to encourage the applicant to come
forward with full and detailed plans for
the site which could then have been
given proper consideration we strongly
urge this committee to take the
opportunity to do what the planning
officer did not do to reflect on the
incremental change history of the site
to remember the applicants declared
intention to build a tourism center to
take him to account the evidence of
local people that this is far from an
established caravan site and to conclude
that this application be refused on the
grounds of its actual rather than
theoretical landscape and dark skies
impact in the AO and be if you do decide
not to do this we do ask that you do two
things one insist on the implementation
of shielding landscaping before the
installation of the pods and to remember
that when the next inter medical
application for this site arrives that
at some time we need to give full
consideration as to whether or not we
want a tourism center in this location
thank you thank you very much councillor
questions yes counselor
good evening counselor cook obviously
long Compton was the first parish to
have the neighborhood plan can you just
tell us what your tourism policy states
we want to encourage tourists we have
promoted bed and breakfasts throughout
the village we've also got arguably the
most successful in in in South
Warwickshire in the Red Lion Inn log
Compton and we have no objections to the
use of the Dutch barn for for holiday
let's what we don't want is some is
grandpa in fact we quite like camping
pods if they could be tucked away
somewhere but actually sticking five
glamping pods right in the middle of the
hill that overlooks the whole of the
village and and impacts the view from
the village and the McMillan way up to
the a OMB when there may be Caravan
stands but there are no caravans a
moment thank you
objection unanimous it from the price
camp was your objection unanimous Ron
yes it was unanimous for male parish
council and Barton parish cancer there
were 10 letters of objection and seven
if support so I just wondered whether
those were taken into account is part
your objection the subject was discussed
and publicized to parish council
meetings because this has taken a bit of
a long time to come through and at
neither were any of the people who were
supporting it did they turn up neither
have you seen the applicant neither have
you seen the planning officer thank you
any other questions that case it
counselor cook thank you very much thank
you very much okay it's okay we go to
Amanda Rogers now the applicants agent
welcome back now I've always got down
rich guy I take it he's not coming today
okey-dokey that's fine well I think you
know the routine you have three minutes
over to you thank you and your office's
report concludes that this application
complies with the development plan and
that planning permission should be
granted it confirms the application
proposes a small scaled tourism use on
the edge of a sustainable settlement
which would generate local employment
and provide support for local service
services and facilities in a way which
is not harmful to recognized interests
this accords with national and local
planning aims which seek to encourage
tourism in the countryside and enhance
the economic conditions of rural areas
even in protected landscape areas the
parish council you have heard have
various concerns about the principle in
this location impact on the LMB that
landscape they didn't mention dark skies
but they've raised it elsewhere and
noise I think they are genuine concerns
but I I'm not convinced that they are
applicable in this location they suggest
that we're looking at a tourism center
that's not true we are looking at to the
conversion of one barn to holiday
cottages and by ramping rods instead of
five caravans the starting point has to
be the national and local policies that
support tourism and economic development
in this location and it has to be the
existing lawful use of the site and the
impact that has all could have on the
wider area so since 2014 this has been
used as a caravan site and will continue
to be used as such once the barn is
converted to the caravan use is expected
to increase considerably we're allowed
to have five caravans with associated
vehicles on that land throughout the
year so the lawful use if not
agricultural it's a touring site for
five caravans and that's what you've got
to determine this proposal against and
the particular issues raised by the
Parish Council five pods have no greater
visual impact on the landscape or the
AUM be than five caravans a pod is
similar in size to a touring Caravan
they're green in color so they match the
backdrop of the heteros behind them and
oddly they're less visible in caravans
where color cannot be controlled there's
no greater lights village associated
with pods than caravans in fact there's
likely to be less light from a pod given
that pod windows are in a single
elevation and caravans have windows on
all elevations the pods are also
positioned behind the existing barn and
as such not visible from the dark sky
site which is near the church parking
and traffic generation is the same for
pods as the caravan site there'll be no
greater impact on wildlife and no
difference in the amount of noise
generated and the applicant is perfectly
happy to accept the condition which
requires additional landscaping if this
is considered necessary to conclude I
don't believe the proposal will have an
adverse impact on the a OMB or the wider
landscape or the dark sky status of long
Compton the application does provide a
sustainable formative turn circuit which
has local benefits not least additional
local employment it complies with the
development plan and I ask that you
grant planning permission in accordance
with your officers recommendation thank
you with three seconds to spare any
questions please yes counselor brain you
said an increase in caravans are you
saying there will be caravans as well as
the glamping pods it will be five
caravans or five jumping pots and the
condition that is proposed by your case
officer on the update sheet it's
specifically designed to remove the
permitted development right that allows
the current caravans so if we implement
any planning permission which might be
forthcoming the caravans are no longer
permitted on the site during caravans
are slightly different because I have
out some facilities on the site
presumably there are already some
facilities on the site waste disposal
and water and a stay at water and sewage
disposal because plumping pods have
their own toilets that means quite some
infrastructure will have to be put in
the infrastructure will be put in anyway
because we have planning permission to
convert the
and barn into to holiday cottages which
may be used either either as one or two
it said flexible use you may recall it
came to committee last summer perhaps
and was granted and so the facilities
will be there anyway the water and the
power will already the waters there the
power will be put in there's already
sewage collection point up there which
is used by the caravans and it will be
in Hollis only to the glamping bottle of
its own separate sewage outlet it will
have its own toilet which will connect
into one waste disposal point which is
to be provided in the corner of the site
and not beyond the northeastern corner
above fee I notice not in their
condition that's why I was asked the
question today I hadn't noticed that but
that's the plan and that was what's been
put forward in the application capsular
fielding my questions along the same
lines because the surgeon area will
there be external lighting if so no okay
so no other questions thank you very
much for your time we don't have a
clarification a comedy condition but the
main reason wasn't conditions at this
point is because caravans are and we've
sort of League on this and because it is
a small representative of the same kind
of as a caravan is the covering of the
caravans act and for that reason the and
with the by an implementation there it
was considered at this time that our
condition may not be enforceable but we
can impose if you wish do only for
coming
so I run the caravan site I know the
internet and with the touring Caravan
you have a mobile tank that you take and
you take it to a Nelson the pod is
different it has to be connected to
Serge because it's got a toilet
the permanent toilet which doesn't go
into a tank I presume
so I see the reason for get there we can
we can attach that okay okay right a
little point use clarification should
get to the debate who would like to
start yeah cat smells thanks rich oh
yeah um yeah my passion my main concern
is the views for the Aon B it's setting
one of the objections that so it can be
seen by from the McMillan way quite
clearly we caravans come and go don't
they but I haven't seen any on there
wasn't anything when I looked there was
some activity up there have to say but
that's probably fecundity officers but
it's just a bit concern that they they
are will be visible from a OMB that's
that's my main concern at the moment but
if as Miranda said they're going to be
no caravans on there that's what we're
saying is that no caravans and replaced
by these on this what everybody else is
I'm not that keen at the moment was Jim
today councillor fielding and council
Perry as far as I'm concerned providing
this sufficient screening and the toilet
and electricity are put in as part of
the conditions I have rarely no
objections to it was it's a bit of land
it's going to be very much connected
into the development of the holiday
let's so it is becoming a sort of
holiday area so I'm proposing it okay
I'll take the proposal
two seconds so you'll be proposing it
presumably with the additional condition
for the disposal okay now I've got
councillor Perry thank you my views
about this that I feel that the glamping
pods are less are visually less harmful
than caravans that are white that stand
out like a sore thumb
I think I think the fact that they're
glamping pods they're green they blend
in I think from an a and I think it's an
improvement to the n OB because I
caravans are normally white and white
stands out on on green so my view is I'm
very happy to second this proposal I
think the glamping pods are a great
improvement as a replacement of five
caravans thank you
yes Council bonds do need to be informed
about the toilets we've got it right I'm
sure it will be right but it is
something that he's over and above what
the caravans old caravans all over the
place thank you well it's been proposed
and second to the councillor brain a
second to work on it okay I'll have my
thoughts while you're working on it I
fully understand the concerns of the
parish council and as the site is at the
moment I can
there's understand this very little
usage of it loaned but as the applicants
agent pointed out we have to understand
what they have commissioned for at the
moment and with that in mind we they
could have five caravans there all the
time and big white blobs I think you're
quite right stand out along so that I'm
sorry I can't permit you to speak in
this part of the meet
thank you I think this will fit better
and we'll have less of an impact
councillor Crump I think I think the
point was made was that the agent had
explained to us about the reasons why it
would have been a good if the agent or
the upper candidates actually spoken to
the parish council to lay their fears
and any misconception so perhaps that
could be noted for future reference and
it might make things go a lot quickly or
a lot smoother and perhaps even we
remove some objections from the
Postclassic okay
Thank You Dale do you have one it's just
imports the conditions are imposed is to
ensure in the redline by injuries no
more car vans will be associated in that
area so we're replacing five caravan so
potentially find caravans that's it all
right dad okay Jeff I'm I'm working on
the basis here that this is a proposal
combined with the conversion of the barn
on that basis I think we can impose a
condition phrase along these lines prior
to the commencement or off development
the means of disposal of foul sewage
shall be submitted to and agreed in
writing with the local planning
authority that needs to be accompanied
with a note and the note needs to say
that the installation of a septic tank
or a packaged sewage treatment works may
require a separate planning permission
that's as I say on the assumption that
the barn will be carried out at the same
time because the barn presumably already
has permission for some sort of packaged
sewage treatment works which this will
connect to if this doesn't connect to
that then a separate permission may be
required for this the works for this
development and I think that covers
everything
you're content then that's good
counselor filming the landscaping is
already in there I think it's already
condition 9 landscaping screening scheme
and replacement within five years okay
on page 74 right it's proposed seconded
we've got a list of additional
conditions all those in favor of
granting please show thank you therefore
the committee resolves to grant
application reference 18 / 0 0 2 5 1 /
ful we go to item 8 okay this is item 8
on page 77 application reference 17 / 0
2 3 8 1 / very this is for village
village swamp importing gaiden and it's
for the variation of condition 8 of
planning permission 0 8 / 0 2 9 4 0 /
ful from there shall be no more than 50
dog kennel kennalt' on the site tell you
one time - there will be no more than
100 dogs can hold on the site at any one
time okay presenting sir
jo look again over to you
I think the heating in here is a bit
sensitive I don't know if we can it gets
a bit temperamental just just think warm
thoughts
all right Joe over to you Thank You chef
the application is for variation a
condition a of planning permission zero
age us to 9 4 0 for there shall be no
more than 50 bulbs kernel on the site at
any one time - there will be no more no
hundred dogs kernel on the site at any
one time the application as indicated by
a black dot on the screen is located
farm pimple lane just outside the
village gaydom as indicated by the red
line mind you on the screen the
application site is located in an open
crunch site approximately 750 meters
from the built-up area boundary of
gayden access to the site is obtained
from pimple lane so this is gayden this
is pimple lane access to the site is
hostile time from there a number of
residential dwellings are located to the
south east of the site which around here
including the African zone this before
you now is a block plant from 2008 which
was approved as part of the permission a
condition that was imposed for a four
meter acoustic bar a to be implemented
to help that neighbor of means is from
possible noise impacts this tradition
was discharged in May 2010 the plan
before you is the block of kennels there
exactly 50 kennels and for planning
considerations the approved ticket
barrier is situated around the Colonel's
surrounding that sort of area I will
show you more and clearer in detail and
photos - forthcoming this is the
Africans house which is situated to the
south east away from the cold
this is the kennels themselves as you
can see this is the Chu state barrier
and means the kernel situated just
behind further shots of the acoustic
barrier arm of the kernels shot off the
kennels and how they are looking this is
to the southeast
so the Africans house is just there
situated and there is residential
property situated just behind that
boundary which aren't obviously in the
Africans ownership and these are views
of the sites around an area this is
course day than very sight woods the
m-40 is situated we just see a little
lawyer there and this is views situated
outwards towards the South East now at
the end of the presentation my
recommendation is to grant planning
permission and there are no updates
thank you thanks Joe right go to Greg
Mitchell the agent please
welcome mr. Mitchell thank you for
waiting sir you have three minutes you'd
remain seated for any questions at the
end yes thank you over to you thank you
Jeff this application has been in for
some time since August of last year at
every stage during the determination
process the applicant has worked closely
with officers to Commission any
additional technical work to address
concerns raised by the Parish Council of
Award member and local residents to
demonstrate that the proposal is
acceptable now set out in the committee
report there are no substantive
objections from county highways or
ecology the District Council's
environmental health officer also raises
no objection the committee report
confirms that the proposal is in
accordance with the relevant policies
the recently adopted core strategy in
terms of the impact on the character of
the area impact on neighboring immediate
II highways and planning policy
considerations there are objections from
the ward member parish council and the
local resident which we have sought to
address I agree with the Planning
Officers assessment that they do not
raise matters material to the
consideration of this section 73
application in the absence of any
corroborating evidence to support the
objections they can only be given very
limited weight anecdotal concerns have
been raised about the welfare of the
dogs on-site the relevant legislative
framework is set out in the committee
report but it is important to note that
the application was accompanied by a
letter from Thomas Bingham who's a
member of the Royal College of
Veterinary Surgeons who was acted as a
veterinary surgeon with the ground
community for about 40 years
in his opinion it's appropriate and also
current practice to have two grounds
kennel together in a single Ken on a
single ground on its own can on
occasions become stress and presents a
bigger noise issue ie constant barking
the addition of another greyhound as a
settling effect reducing both stress and
noise concerns have been raised about
the disposal of waste but again we
provided information to the planning
officer
in the last couple of days to explain
how that waste disposal is handled I'm
pleased to say that working
cooperatively with the council we've
produced the robust proposal by the
officers have been able to provide a
clear statement of the acceptability of
the proposal in terms of all the
relevant planning considerations in my
opinion therefore the only reasonable
decision is to grant planning permission
thank you thank you any questions yes
roughly probably around 600 meters and
what noise is generated good it can be
heard from the site from from the m-40
well the the site itself is a higher
elevation than the motorway so noise
from the motorway impacts upon the site
it's if you are on the site depending on
the weather conditions the noise on the
motorway drowns out almost everything
really yep okay that's fine thank you
yes councillor fielding sorry no it's
it's a commercial operation that relates
to greyhound racing it's quite an
interesting situation really because the
dogs that are on site they are taken in
an afternoon usually about 3:30 to a dog
track in the Midlands or South Midlands
and the majority of the dogs go in the
company vehicle the single company
vehicle that's on the site and then they
take part in the races that take place
at the the dog the the dog track so
owners do visit the site but they they
only visit the site between the hours of
10:30 and 12:30 on a Sunday and normally
that's about 4 vehicles and
this information to set out in the
transport state they don't think you
have circulation thank you very much
Calipari oh okay Thank You chair my
questions been answered thank you
just going on with regards to greyhounds
particularly where their useful life is
over what happens to the dogs then are
they okay I just don't think it's
relevant to the application sorry
well it's about numbers it's not about
burials okay yes okay right any other
questions
okay thank you very much very much
chairman lovely okay we don't have a
ward member with us so points
clarification yes Caliban mr. chairman
wish where the Parish Council objected
and didn't turn up in the ward member
the Chairman proposed the application we
and has no discussion that that's need
to be the format that we used I'm quite
happy to propose this applicator
well the other points of clarification
I'll take that as a proposition to grant
anybody else have a second if you get a
second or I should say I'm very happy to
second it I do know a little bit about
greyhounds not though I'm a betting
person but I do know certainly when
greyhounds are retired they do try to
retire them in pairs because they are
dogs that are quite highly strung and
they are more settled if they are
impaired so I would be in support of
this application
we second again thank you sir missed
that okay propose a second up all those
in favor please show thank you
therefore the committee results to grant
application reference 17 / 0 to 3 H 1 /
very go to our final item tonight nearly
that we did okay
18 / 0 0 1 7 9 / bury this crowd house I
Street napkin on the hill is for the
variation of condition - Planning
Commission reference 15 / 0 0
seven seven nine slash ful dated second
October 2015 to retrospectively alter
the design of the approved windows on
the front elevation indicated on the
drawing right percent Lee officers chair
again over to you thank you Jeff
the application for variation in
condition to of planning permission 15
star zero zero seven nine full to
retrospectively alter the design of the
pretty windows on the front elevation
reference eighteen star zero zero one
seven nine four as indicated on the
black dot on screen the application
cited within Knutson on hill the Crown
Heights is a former public house
currently being converted to a single
dwelling house located century we live
in the village of Martin on the hill is
positioned in close proximity to the
village green and walking distance from
a number of residential properties that
are central within the village the
thoughts building is a free story and as
painted brick finish is set back from
the main road for the village by
approximately twenty meters were an area
passed under the front for turning
vehicles you will be out to review all
this in the photos that are forthcoming
there is an access to the south side
which leads to the carpark associated
with the pub while them easy to really
building there's the garden the Hope has
been expended to the rear with a number
of our politicians and barrelling roof
stocks there is a residential property
need lead to the north which sits a
slightly higher level due to growing
levels rising that would stir north the
neighbor neighbor and property is great
to list his own and facts building which
is full high extension to the side and
is in close proximity to the application
this is a painted render finish with
tiled roof as you can see the
application needs a trip art
retrospective this is at a time of the
site visit please note the the windows
that have been installed part of this
application on the first floor and on
the side extension we saw show you more
clearly
are not the windows that are being
proposed to this application the above
windows on the second floor are for the
windows that have been imposed to this
application this is a closer view of the
windows of the two second-floor windows
and now obviously the brick paint
finisher and of the client house once
again these are not the windows being
posed even though they have been
installed this is a side extension of it
and shows the window which is also being
proposed to be removed and replaced so
these are the three plans on the top on
the top right the top left hand corner
is three pounds of 2015 as you can see
the ferry in contrast in the application
styles and these are the place pants
this application as you will note from
the previous photographs these do differ
and they are so in all pains within the
windows on all applications apart from
the second floor which is saying the
ground floor windows are different from
what was approved in 2015 by style and
contrast but I've not been implemented
that on the site visit these photos
taken directly adjacent to the crown
house now as you will note the varying
contrast in styles of the windows around
there and there is ample I'm thankful
for a high T of windows and stars within
the area thank you though
also there is a lot of evidence to you
PC Windows which is being proposed as
part of this application and therefore
it doesn't look contact this is the
listed building in the fact roof this is
the the former pub which is now a
residential property these as you can
see by the windows at once again have
different panes and once again on the
hotmail higher-up is also the varying
contrast of windows this is looking
directly adjacent
up to the hill so the pub is situated to
the sorry for this photograph and once
again you can see the different styles
especially within the residential
property is almost immediately Jason and
all these windows are uPVC
this is an finally approved plan well
with the proposed plan and as you can
tell these are the windows that are
being proposed once again I do after
highlighter and these are the
ground-floor windows which haven't been
implemented
once again the second-floor windows at
the minute have been respectively in
place and that is the end of my
presentation recommendation is to ground
and there is no update thank you
excellent thank you very much Joe right
councillor Richard Woodcock please as
our first speaker from Neptune Parish
Council welcome thank you for waiting so
long as well so you have three minutes
if you remain seated for any questions
at the end
over to you okay thank you ladies and
gentlemen I'm here on behalf of Knapton
Parish Council as approach counselor but
also of course on behalf of the village
and the building has been described to
you it's not a listed building but it is
however a very historic building and
it's a building that the village has
great affection for being the former
village pub and when it was changed or
the application was approved for it to
be changed from a pub to a house that
was quite a traumatic situation for the
village however it was approved and the
village took some solace for the fact
that the front facade of the building
would remain unchanged so any
alterations that were approved are out
of sight round the back of the building
now to say this is a historic building
and although not listed it can be seen
in numerous photographs going back to
Victorian times and has never changed
during its history it's situated on the
top of the village green and although
that is not a conservation area it is an
area which is the very center of the
village and it is an area which has been
considered as a conservation area the
windows that are being installed are
completely contrary to the permission
that is currently in place and so this
application is retrospective whatever
he's decided those windows that have
already been installed will need to be
replaced and the windows on the
ground-floor have yet to be installed so
in other words whatever these windows
are replaced with there will be no
additional cost than if this application
is approved or not
the village contends that the applicant
hasn't imposed these windows
accidentally it's been done deliberately
contrary to the planning permission and
the village would like to see this
committee reject the application for the
windows that have now been submitted and
returned to the original application
which the village was happy with and
which was passed by planning some time
ago thank you very much councillor any
questions for the parish council
accounts actually speak to the parish
council specifically about the windows
no there was a loss of liaison with the
applicant before the application went in
for the conversion of the pub to our
house but there's been no conversation
regarding the windows they just appeared
one day and there was a lot of discord
in the village thank you
yes councillor Mills thank you good
evening the windows that are going to be
replaced are going to look like this
okay now we accept that there are a long
way towards and being better than the
ones that are in there at the moment but
they still not was approved originally
and they do change the character and
facade of the pub which is been
prevalent in the village for at least
150 years we don't know what that both
of these are up there so the top picture
is the approved design and the bottom
picture is what's being proposed was the
change yeah but obviously there was the
phone dose before those ones are gonna
be taken at the regional the original
windows are different from those two I
take it now the original windows the
same as the ones have approved on the
top yeah and I might add that there are
wooden sash windows now there is no
condition for them to be wouldn't sash
the replacements will be PVC so the
change of visual impact is quite
dramatic and this is a site that's got a
horse chestnut tree in front of it that
was planted in commemoration of the
coronation of George v so it's a very
historic part of the village
okay are there any further questions
councillor fielding there or you prove
Georgie on Windows to do sliding sliding
windows such weathers saturate Oh as I
say the original windows for such
windows they were wooden and to be fair
they needed replacement the applicant
was putting his plans in which had been
approved for Georgian windows and it
doesn't specify the material that was
perhaps remiss at the time but
nevertheless that's what's approved and
on the ground floor you want those
smaller windows correct we want it to
look like it's always looked at case if
there are no other questions thank you
very much for your time tonight we yes
go to Council Williams board member
welcome again so five minutes I first
heard about this problem on the 9th of
November when the parish council phoned
me and said what has been putted in this
house and this is a Friday didn't seem
to match what was approved some two
years previously
they'd been two years but he could have
changed design apply to us just a
modification so I phoned the enforcement
officer phoned the applicant and the
applicant said good god I didn't know
about that I'll have a word with the
Builder and the verbal response I was
given was the Builder business is a
mistake it will be corrected ho ho then
various requests for myself is what's
happening from the parish council and
the setting which you didn't show in the
photographs if you approach Knapton we
just like the North Face of the Eiger
it's one Hill all the way around but as
you come down the hill the decison front
view is this building which is
historical as you already heard and we
repeatedly told oh they've had a word
with the applicant yes the builders
correcting his mistake but he never
retracted his mistake now you could have
say is it really worth making a fuss
about a bit of plastic in a window it is
because we have these regulations that
were approved
they weren't varied there were some
attempts to variation was whether you
have wood steel aluminium and that's all
thing yes in principle it's nearly right
but in fact it's wrong and I think we
can just say oh it doesn't make a
difference it does make a difference the
people adapt and they hold this pub in
high-risk esteem
they're very much opposed to changes to
private house but that was changed one
of the conditions they were stressed was
it will still maintain the image of the
old pub before change back this is none
of that so I'd ask you really
I don't think it's acceptable they
should as a the applicant promised
before Christmas he would have a weapons
developer and change now why did he
change it in the last two months
probably because it's too much bother
but I think we've got a ball on this one
it might be a small detail by the detail
is important
thank you cancer Williams any questions
to the ward member thank you very much
there okay points clarification any
council Mills thanks bishop so on from
the original application was it was it
or not stated they're going to be wooden
windows wood frames or not perhaps you
can't read it from where you are
counselor but if you look at the top
left hand corner the annotation is
replace existing windows with
high-performance uPVC windows was that
was originally approved plans in 2015
yeah you'll be able to see if they don't
think up that was far too small but you
can just you can like I see it on this
one right so people we're clear then
what it was going to be yeah okay thank
you any of the clarification points
[Music]
that's the difference visually they're
white they look the same so there's a
slight difference there on the ground
floor the windows considerably different
there is a difference there I think the
upper floors I agree with you but the
dance the ground floor is different I'm
sorry I'm afraid I can't let you speak
at this point
yes counsel fielding I believe that we
approved 15 the the windows and the
style of the windows maybe the material
was different but I think the Builder
and the owner should be kept to what was
approved at the time it it makes it
keeps the tradition of the house and the
building the pub whereas the proposal is
large building windows on the ground
floor I think throw the whole thing out
of balance
it's something that's been in the in the
area for off a number of years and I
don't see why he should be allowed to
get away with changing the ground
particularly the ground for Windows
Thank You chair my concerns relate on at
the end of the day we approved plans
that set the scene in terms of design
and distinctiveness which falls into cs9
if I'm right
my concern is is is around a precedent
here and I'm concerned that if we
deviate from an approved from an
approved plan are we opening ourselves
up for of other matters
I appreciate its windows but windows are
seriously important and I do think it it
is a landmark building in terms of where
the village is and my view is is that it
should the the approve plans should
remain in situ we don't create a
precedent I mean because you accept each
application on its own merits I
understand what you're saying it's you
know you feels like you would be but
you're not
councilor fielding then Council balance
yes nine full approved plan rather than
think what you're actually doing is
you're proposing
to refuse the application yes okay okay
out us if the first roll has come back
to planning reasons really so what are
your planning reasons for proposing
refusal then we'll need a second my
planning reasons are along the lines
that counselor Perry referred to and I
think we should keep it to the
conditions I think I'm looking at this
and I think I understand where people
going in terms of it's important to
maintain what was there before but I
think we can't lose sight of the fact
that this is a planning application to
very and should the applicant wish to
they could go and have an appeal after
this and the appeal would focus on
whether or not we are being reasonable
I'm looking this and while I completely
understand the parish councils grievance
here you I really do understand that
makes a lot of sense but somebody who's
from outside the air will come in and
objectively look at this and they say
what is the harm being caused by the
changes now we've already accepted the
upstairs is almost identical the
materials we see they've been granted
for uPVC already so it's not a it's not
a change of materials being used and so
we come to the ground floor and while
it's different
I don't know I'm seeing significant harm
in terms of the difference buildings
evolve over time as do villages
I'm sure the parent that the people of
the village wanted to keep this as a per
bike I understand that and yeah I would
have done too but it has changed the
building is still there and part of the
community I think it will be
unreasonable not to allow some changes
in terms of the windows and I think they
are minor that's my view it has been
proposed that we refuse and we can still
continue with that but I need to ask for
a second
yes council bounce
115 has been deviated to enforcement
it's been looked at it and that's why we
have this application far as I'm
concerned I appreciate the concern of
the village and the pub but looking at
it it isn't going to make a great lot of
difference so I can't see a reason for
fusional well that's it I'll patch it do
you have any like planning reasons or
okay do we have a second if accounts or
Fielding's proposal to refuse okay in
that case so accounts filling it falls
and it's proposed by counterbalance to
to grab the application do you have a
seconder yeah yeah let's Labre thank you
if there's nobody else wishing to speak
on this let's trim proposed and seconded
that we grant the application all those
in favor please show we do that again
okay there's games yes
both against one abstentions that's
right thank you all right thank you
therefore the committee resolves to
grant application reference 18 / 0 0 1 7
9 / very which is our last item in
tonight's agenda thank you very much
everybody
much appreciate the meeting is meeting
we do that offer meeting is closed